[Music]
there's been all these rumors that maybe
you guys have moved to Nashville are you
ready to live in Nashville yeah so we've
actually had her house there for about
six years we would spend summers there
and the offseason now both my boys are
in school so it's been harder to break
away but this has always been the plan
the plan was always to move to Nashville
when Jay was done with football but even
if he were to play I would still move to
Nashville with the kids and stay put
only because whatever he ends up doing
would be for such a short amount of time
I don't want to bounce my kids around
too much so I'd rather just move to
Nashville get them situated get them in
their school and then um you know post
up and we'll see you when we see a J
well Nashville that's hilarious
Nashville has become Hollywood South in
a lot of ways yeah it's I love Nashville
it's fun it's beautiful there's a great
food scene um you know Jaimie to
Vanderbilt so we have a lot of good
friends there and we're really excited
about the future we just are
[Music]